el mundo podría enfrentarse a una crisis
alimentaria como consecuencia de la
guerra en ucrania y las consecuencias de
estas acciones han sido devastadoras el
suministro de alimentos para millones de
ucranianos y millones más en todo el
mundo ha sido literalmente rehén de los
militares rusos
este país europeo es el quinto
exportador mundial de trigo y junto a
rusia suman un tercio de la producción
mundial de este grano ucrania además
está entre los tres primeros
exportadores de maíz cebada y semillas
de girasol pero los bloqueos a los
puertos terminado que han hecho los
ucranianos cercan las costas y los
bombardeos rusos a los almacenes de
cereales en ucrania han afectado la
producción y exportación de estos
productos
hoy la artillería rusa está bombardeando
almacenes de grano en ucrania
deliberadamente y los barcos de guerra
ruso en el mar negro están bloqueando
los barcos ucranianos llenos de trigo y
semilla de girasol las consecuencias de
estos actos vergonzosos están a la vista
de todos los precios mundiales de trigo
se disparan y son los países frágiles y
las poblaciones vulnerables los que más
sufren
sin embargo moscú niega haber atacado
objetivos civiles y agrícolas y culpa
las sanciones de occidente de la caída
de las exportaciones de alimentos y del
aumento de los precios mundiales
reaccionó
en cuanto al grano hemos explicado que
puede ser transportado libremente a su
destino rusia no está poniendo ningún
obstáculo en el camino para ello es
necesario que el señor selenski dé la
orden si es que todavía está al mando de
algo allí de permitir que los barcos
extranjeros y ucranianos entren al mar
negro
pero la onu desconfía de estas
declaraciones y ha presentado un plan
para reabrir las rutas marítimas desde
odessa y otros puertos ucranianos
mientras que ucrania ha establecido dos
rutas por tierra a través de polonia y
rumanía para exportar granos y conversa
con los países bálticos para añadir un
tercer corredor sin embargo estas rutas
tienen una capacidad mucho más limitada
de transporte de carga que las marítimas